21h30 les hommes ferme l'accès une
portion de la rd 30 entre le giratoire
des gâtines est celui du petit saint
cloud la circulation est totalement
coupée pour permettre l'installation de
la passerelle du bois de la crâne est en
fait la dernière étape de cette
opération qui consistait à réaliser une
passerelle pour les piétons les cycles
pour rétablir donc un chemin de
randonnée gr 11 donc et un chemin qui va
des stands où est donc cette passerelle
qui a été mise en place cette nuit va
servir effectivement à rétablir cette
circulation piétons et cycles un ouvrage
de 110 tonnes assemblée sur le chantier
installé grâce à une grue géante la
passerelle devrait être accessible au
public dans le courant du premier
trimestre 2011 21 il va falloir être
patient encore un petit peu
il reste effectivement des petits
aménagements à faire donc
bourdy en béton donc pour pouvoir
circuler sur la passerelle et puis
aménager les rampes d'accès de part et
d'autre donc ça va prendre encore
quelques semaines
d'un coût de 80 7 millions d'euros
financés par le département et la région
ile de france
le chantier de la rd 30 à débuter en
il a permis de doubler la capacité de
cette route départementale en 2018
plus de trente mille véhicules
empruntent chaque jour